the infographic show is a popular
animated YouTube channel that covers
topics in basically every category from
economics and medicine the politics and
challenges their innovative approach to
shed light on various topics in a fun
and intriguing way has allowed them to
grow the channel to a massive 8.3
million subscribers with over 1,800
videos and over 2.2 billion views at
this point it's just a matter of time
until they reached a 10 million
subscriber mark but this begs a question
through all of this how much money has
the infographic show actually made
well to estimate their earnings we have
to first take a look at the revenue
sources the main ones that come to mind
are YouTube ad revenue video sponsors
and affiliate links starting with
YouTube ad revenue generally education
channels get a solid 10 to $15 CPM or
basically 10 to 15 dollars per thousand
views but this is generally only for
channels with a super defined niche
whether that's live in stock investing
or stimulus checks for a channel such as
an infographic show with a broad
audience their CPM is likely not as high
and is probably in the 7 to 10 dollar
range to estimate conservatively however
we'll assume their overall CPM is $5
which they can easily get especially
considering that many of the videos
crossed the 10-minute mark along from
multiple ad breaks last month they got
155 million views but this is largely
fueled by the pandemic and the influx of
people staying at home so a more
accurate figure would be looking at
their viewership over the past year for
about a year now
they've been hovering in the 80 to 100
million users per month range so well
estimated they get 90 million views a
month which would mean that they pull in
450 thousand dollars a month just an ad
revenue ask for video sponsors however
it actually seems like they've moved
away from using video sponsors in their
videos of course we've all seen them
plug blue apron Skillshare dashlane
audible and of course Wix but after
going through all of the videos they
posted over the past month which is a
lot as opposed to videos every single
day I didn't see any sponsor videos in
fact the last sponsor video I could find
was from February where they had a
sponsorship with Monday com this is
probably just because of the pandemic as
advertisers are being more careful after
looking through their earliest videos it
seems like their first sponsor video
started about three years ago in June of
2017 to find out the frequency in which
they add video sponsors I went through
all the videos they posted in January of
2020 which is the month with the least
advertisers
to again estimate conservatively after
going through 65 videos I found that 17
out of the 65 videos I posted has
sponsors or a little more than 25% so
subtracting 180 videos for the videos
post over the past three months and
another 60 for their first videos
without sponsors about 1580 videos
laying the period where they were
actively using video sponsors this means
that they have about 400 sponsored
videos a survey conducted by my work
from home money comm founds the meeting
and amount paid per view by sponsors is
8.9 cents the infographics show however
makes a large brand deals with companies
so it's likely that the sponsors of
their videos pay less than this plus
their audience isn't as niche
so we'll just save 5 cents per view
dividing their total views by the total
fee account we can see that the average
over 1.2 million views per video but
this is really not true as this is
largely fueled by some of the most
popular videos which garner tens of
millions of views in fact today most of
the videos get 200 to 300 thousand views
but I think this can be attributed to
running out of video ideas and less
unique video ideas as they move forward
as it simply makes so many videos in
their heyday about a year ago each of
their videos was getting millions of
views so let's just say their average
sponsored video gets about 500 thousand
views even at 5 cents per view each of
these videos would bring in twenty five
thousand dollars with about 17 of these
per month they bring in about 425
thousand dollars a month in sponsorships
and have brought about 10 million
dollars from their 400 sponsored videos
you can see why many creators love doing
sponsored videos but that's not it from
the sponsors the links in the
description are generally affiliate
links leading to even more revenue for
instance wicks pays a whopping 100
dollars for every single premium user
who were further away the median
click-through rate for YouTube
sponsorships is about 4 to 7 percent
given the broad infographics audience
however let's give them a below-average
3% CTR once these guys get to the
sponsors website that average conversion
rate in the US is 2.63 percent while the
average global conversion rate is four
point three one percent so let's just
say the average conversion rate overall
is about three percent
this means that sponsors get a cell
every 1,111 in video views or
approximately every limit on reviews so
every sponsored video would produce
about 450 cells for the company now as
for the affiliate Commission workspace
one our dollars per cell audible offers
between $0.50 and $10 per cell
Skillshare offers $10 per cell and other
companies like dashlane we can't tell
what the action being for their partner
but the average seems to be between 5 to
$10 with some odd balls like Wix at a
hundred so let's say the average
Commission is $10 with 450 sales per
sponsorship the infographics show would
pull in 4,500 dollars per video from
affiliate marketing with about 17
sponsored videos per month this would
generate another seventy six thousand
five hundred dollars a month or about
1.8 million dollars over their entire
YouTube channel considering all of this
the infographics show pulls in a
conservative nine hundred fifty thousand
dollars on average per month or twenty
three point one eight million over their
entire channel can you believe that's
just conservative with the ten dollar
CPM hire sponsorship revenue and higher
click-through rates it's possible to the
infographic show has made upwards of 50
million dollars over the past few years
and up to two million dollars a month on
average but wait don't go anywhere just
yet as that's just revenue they have to
pay for the production of all of their
videos as I doubt one guy is just
sitting at home pumping out 60 animated
videos a month to calculate their
profits
let's just say that they made right in
between our conservative and Maxim
estimates and estimate the monthly
revenue to be 1.5 million dollars in a
total revenue to be 37 point 5 million
dollars if they were to take the
industrial route and hire
humming major videos it would cost them
between one thousand to five thousand
dollars for every minute of their
infographic video but the thing is their
videos aren't making animations from
scratch but this company is probably
offering most of the videos are made
from templates making the job much
easier but even if they were to go with
the company they'd likely be able to get
the cheap 1,000 dollar amount due to how
much business they're giving them with
an average length of 10 minutes each of
their videos would cost about $10,000
leading to six hundred thousand dollars
a month in production costs even then
they profit a solid six hundred thousand
dollars a month but we know that they
don't do this they actually have a team
of 40 freelancers who make all of your
videos in fact you can apply to work for
them on their website it looks to me
that they are basically firing all of
your production but without Fiverr
cutting out the middleman but despite
this we can look on Fiverr to get a good
estimate of how much you're paying for
this work two of the most popular
creators in this niche of animated
explainer videos charge $150 per 30
seconds and $120 per 40 seconds
translating to about 180 to $300 per
minute fortunately for the infographic
show however they have volume
consistency and a robust catalog of
templates on their side these Fiverr
listings also offer voiceovers as well
but I think the infographics show has
their own team of voice actors separate
from the video editors however it is
likely that they also give the task of
creating thumbnails to the video editors
so let's say they pay about $200 for
each minute of video editing coming out
to $2,000 for a 10 minute video aside
from this we also have the task of
thinking of video ideas and script
writing as those voice actors the
average person speaks out 125 to 150
words per minute but an explainer video
is likely a talk slower to make it
easier to understand so at 125 word per
minute the average video would have
about 1,250 words to 5 our top sellers
are charging 280 and $325 for this eye
again with volume let's say this cost
$250 per video for the infographic show
ask for the script itself
there's not many Fiverr sellers offering
this but one is charging about $9 for a
script however an infographic show
script writer would also have to come up
with the idea itself and do a fair bit
of research so let's give the average
infographic show script writer 1000
dollars per video the editing script
writing and voiceovers would come out to
three thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars of video but there's also author
will work like actually posting on
YouTube interacting with the audience
and writing descriptions they would also
need people to contact companies and
handle sponsorship deals as well as pay
for any subscriptions like Adobe
Premiere Pro and their template as well
as sound and music resource fortunately
for them as all of their employees seem
to be freelancers working remotely there
would be no need to pay for office space
and internet connection property tax and
computers and all that stuff so let's
just say the average infographics show
video costs four thousand dollars to
make we can now figure out that each
month's production cost would be about
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
and their overall production costs
across our entire channel is likely
around seven point three million dollars
with all of this we can finally figure
out that the infographics show makes
about 1.25 million dollars per month and
30 million dollars over the entire
YouTube channel in profit but wait there
is one more thing to look at as well
which is how much is the infographic
show actually worth well to estimate
this we have to take a look at their net
income or the income after taxes the
infographics show is owned by an
American named Andres Preston and most
of the success has come after Trump tax
bill so his business would be taxed at
21% and I don't think they have many tax
deductibles because all her business is
online this would mean that the net
income of the infographic show would be
right at 1 million dollars a month or
about twelve million dollars per year
generally companies are worth sixteen
point five times their yearly earnings
but since it seems like the infographics
show has already experienced a peak
after growth
and again to estimate conservatively
will use a p/e ratio or price to
earnings ratio of ten meaning that the
infographic show is worth about 120
million dollars so in summary the
infographic show is a 9 figure YouTube
business earns 12 million dollars a year
in net income
did you expect that comment down below
and if you guys thought this video
provided a thorough analysis on the
infographic shows earnings then drop a
like and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm hari now I'll see you
guys on the next one